[Music]
the whole idea of best interests in the
question why do people vote against
their best interests is not an objective
thing in nature right it's one of the
very problems in the politics of
inevitability is that we think like
economists and we say well everybody has
everybody's rational in the narrow
economical sense everybody knows what's
good for them and that's just not true
or rather the ability of people to
discern what their interests are depends
upon a process of Education which
includes not just reasoning
mathematically which is very important
but also it has to include some kind of
humanistic side where people learn to
criticize or think critically about what
they hear learn to be learn to make
distinctions among various kinds of
media because that that notion of one's
best interest it's not at all natural
it's the product of a certain kind of
education and that kind of education can
be undone I mean first of all it cannot
be done but could also be undone one can
deliberately appeal to the parts of the
mind which aren't concerned with the
future with math with critical thinking
but to the parts of the mind which think
in terms of us in them friend and enemy
and you can draw people into these
cycles right and the less that P and
this is how it fits together with
inequality the less people see a good
future for themselves if they think in
terms of interests the more they're
drawn into a different way of thinking
where it's not about their individual
interests but it's more about feeling
like they're on the right team they're
on the right side right for a lot of
people in the u.s. now I think it's a
little bit like they want to ride the
bench for the winning team you know they
know that things aren't going well for
them personally but they want to feel
like they're on the right side and that
helps to explain the appeal of someone
like a Donald Trump who of course
himself is a failure but has the skills
to present himself
as a success and can get people thinking
yeah I want to be on that team I'm gonna
feel I'm not gonna do any better
economically but I'm gonna feel better
about myself because I'm on the winning
team I don't know it feels like the
winning team so the whole the whole
thing about best interests has to be
seen as a project you have to educate
people you have to take anxiety away by
providing certain basic things like
schooling and pensions and vacations so
people can pause and think a little bit
about themselves and their future if you
don't provide those basic elements of I
would say it political civilization then
people are too anxious like it's hard
for them to get their minds around what
you know what their interests actually
are and beyond that if you don't give
them if you don't educate them
positively towards thinking with both
math and with the humanities they're not
they're not going to get there anyway
so it's a project I mean a basic thing
that we Americans forget and a basic
thing that politics of inevitability
shrouds is that creating the individual
is a project it takes a lot of work to
create an individual I mean we want to
have thinking individuals we want to
have people who know what their best
interests are we want to have people who
go thoughtfully into that ballot box
right but that's a project we're not
born that way right I mean as a father I
can assure you that we are not born that
way
it's I think like it's the noblest and
best thing we do to try to create
individuals but we can't just leave it
to chance and I think that's where we go
wrong one of the basic ways we go wrong
with the politics of inevitability we
think okay automatically we're gonna be
those kinds of rational people but we're
not automatically those kinds of
rational people I mean the the irony is
if you want to create individuals who
can think about their own best interests
you have to as a society say we agree to
make it a project to educate and form
such individuals
[Music]